-I just want to say
happy birthday to you.
Your birthday was yesterday.
-Yesterday, man.
-Happy birthday!
-Thank you, brother.
-You're the best.
Come on, man
-Thank you.
-Best of the best.
Good luck
and many, many, many more years.
-Thank you.
-Did you have fun?
-Yes.
You know, I chilled.
Last year was 50, so it's 51,
so last year we did a big one.
This year --
-What?
-I know, baby.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm joking, I'm joking.
-Wow!
-But, like, last year
was a big blowout,
so this year, quiet was nice.
Like, a small dinner,
play some golf.
I always celebrated
with a friend of mine,
Peter Hochfelder.
And he turned 60, and I was 50,
so last year,
we did a 110th birthday.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-So this year we just keep on,
112th this year.
Whatever, but we just chilled.
It was nice.
-Are you having
a good season here?
Because the Giants are doing --
Well, I know they lost.
-Oh, they lost,
but they've won more games
than I thought
they were gonna win,
so it's a great year.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Everyone's kind of happy
in New York.
-Yeah.
-Even the Jets.
-The Giants are winning.
The Jets are winning.
Even when they lose,
people are still wearing gear.
People are wearing stuff --
I haven't seen a Giants hat
or shirt or jacket in 10 years.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's psyched.
-No one's asked me
for a ticket in 10 years.
[ Laughter ]
And now my own kids are like,
"Can I get tickets to the game?"
I'm like, "You didn't care.
I even played!"
-"I was one of the greatest
Giants to play the game ever."
-But it's good to see
the excitement back.
I think -- you know, football
is so unpredictable.
That's what I love about it.
-Yeah.
-So unpredictable.
-Well, you know better
than anyone New York is
a pretty tough place to play.
-Oh, yeah.
-I mean, when you win,
you're the top of the world,
when you lose...
-You're under the shoe.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Did you ever get that
when you were playing here?
-Oh, yeah, man.
Fans here are brutal.
-Yeah.
-They tell you how they feel.
They don't --
"Oh, it'll be next time."
No, no, no.
"You sucked yesterday."
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"You suck."
-And to the point where
you're afraid to go out to eat.
-Really?
-Oh!
When we lost,
I didn't want to go out to eat.
I didn't even want to go
to the drive-through.
They would be like, "Here,
take your burgers, you punk!"
[ Laughter ]
-"See if --" yeah.
"See if you catch this."
-"I'll cook at home."
-Yeah.
You're known as one of
the greatest defensive players
of all time, but you also --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sure.
-Thank you.
-Of all time.
Of all time.
-I just -- yeah, it's hard
to even hear, but...
-But you also scored
three touchdowns
throughout your career.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We have one of them.
Here's Michael Strahan's
game-winning touchdown.
-This was about
40 pounds ago, probably.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
Here's your winning touchdown
against the Philadelphia Eagles
in 1999.
Take a look at this.
-From the 45 yard line,
third down play for the Eagles.
Peterson gets time.
The pass is blocked!
-Yeah! Go, Michael Strahan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Michael Strahan
headed for the end zone!
-Yo!
-Strahan, touchdown!
And the Giants win!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Discordant notes playing ]
-Stop it!
He's a guest!
He is a guest on this show!
Stop that!
-[ Laughing ]
-He is a guest on our program!
-Okay.
I will be honest with you,
it's great to score a touchdown.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's great.
But when you do it against
the Eagles, in overtime,
in Philly,
and I can look y'all in the face
when it's going on...
[ Laughter ]
...it's the best ever!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What I like is -- You know,
if you score a touchdown,
everyone's got to move.
They got different things.
If you spike it or you could do
a dance or do something.
You just kind of went like...
-Oh!
There was --
No, there was a reason.
Because the Friday
before that Sunday game,
I went to see Ricky Martin.
Me and some of my --
[ Laughter ]
Me and my teammates, we went to
see Ricky Martin at the Garden.
-Yeah.
-And Ricky would come out,
and before he even did anything,
he would just go like this.
And the crowd was like, "Wow!"
[ Laughter ]
So I said,
"If I score a touchdown,
I'm gonna hit them
with the Ricky Martin."
[ Laughter ]
And so I scored that --
I had never thought
I was gonna score a touchdown.
It happened that,
two days later,
and I hit them
with a Ricky Martin.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a great story.
-Hey.
-But the thing about Philly,
they were hitting me
with, like, stuff
they spit in the cups,
and they'd throw -- yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So, they hit me back.
-Yeah, they got you back.
Can we talk about this
new podcast you're doing here?
-Oh, yeah.
-"American Football:
How the Gridiron was Forged."
Kate Mara.
Talk about this.
This is how football started,
the whole history?
-Yeah.
It's the history of football.
Like, I love football,
and I thought I knew
about the history of the game,
but this is
the real history of the game,
how it started.
Football used to be,
like, white-collar,
and then the blue-collar teams
wanted to play, and they said,
"Nope, you can't play."
So they kind of developed
their own leagues.
And it's just
a history of all that.
And, also,
we have modern-day broadcasters,
from Joe Buck to Curt Menefee,
they are calling
some of the older games,
like narrating some of the older
games, which is really cool.
And Kate Mara, what a lot
of people may not know,
is a dear friend.
I've known her
since she was a kid --
who now has kids
and was pregnant
and just had a kid last week
in the booth doing this.
-Did she, really?
-She is a part of two dynasties.
The Pittsburgh Steelers
and the New York Giants.
Those are her parents.
-That's right.
-So she is a part
of two dynasties
and the perfect partner
to narrate this for us.
She knocks it out of the water.
-Talk about fun projects
to work on.
You told me about this
last time.
You were like,
"We can't mention it yet."
-Yeah, couldn't mention it.
-Yeah, because this is
top-secret stuff.
Your own skincare line.
-See, that's why
I don't look 51.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the secret.
That's the secret.
You moisturize.
-I moisturize, man.
You know, as men,
doing this job,
you do have to wear a little
makeup here and there.
-Of course.
-I just consider mine to be
anti-shine, not really makeup.
[ Laughter ]
But -- But --
-Oh, my gosh.
-You know, and I think we just
go through the grit
and the grime of the day,
and we run around.
And for men, it seems
inconvenient
to take care of your skin.
But to me, like, wearing
a nice outfit, it's confidence.
Taking care of your skin
is confidence.
So we developed this system,
and it's very easy to do.
The face wash
and the moisturizer.
Then there's a beard oil
and a shaving gel.
-What do you do with beard oil?
-Beard oil.
Yeah, hey, by the way,
this is a great beard.
Y'all like his beard?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm in the beard game.
I just --
I haven't seen you since --
-Do you use beard oil?
-65-years-old, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
-But do you use beard oil?
-No, I have no idea
what beard oil is at all.
-Come here.
Let me see something.
Oh, very coarse.
Well, your beard
is pretty coarse.
-Yeah, it's rough, right?
-Yeah, like a horse.
[ Laughter ]
-Doesn't feel like a horse!
-But seriously,
you should use beard oil.
-What would I do?
How would I use beard oil?
-You got a little thing here.
You just put a little few drops
right there.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, come here.
You know, I'm gonna give you
star treatment.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Whoa.
Wow.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah. Oh!
Oh, I feel like a million bucks.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Michael Strahan,
Daily Defense Beard Oil.
That's what I'm talking about!
-That simple.
-I feel good!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't even --
I don't even need it.
-You don't.
-We got some oils in there.
You can just rub it into
your cuticles, actually.
-See, that's
what I'm talking about.
He knows
what he's talking about.
-Multitasking.
Michael Strahan, everybody.
Michael Strahan Daily Defense
is available now on Amazon
and MichaelStrahanSkin.com.
Michael and I are doing
something fun after the break.
Stick around.